lors des séries
j'aime bien cette émission à l'émotion
en direct dedans comme quand tu rentres
chez toi et tu es content cette fois-ci
hier dans des chiffres et des lettres
on a assisté à un gros dilemme nancy
balle à un candidat a fait le choix de
proposer que deux mots alors qu'il
pouvait clairement proposé trois passes
les cieux ouais ça risquait de le faire
passer pour un pervers du coup c'est
dommage mais il a joué la sécurité
ce que vous avez pilotes le tirage j'ai
d é à ffl tient il pas fait gifler oui
[Applaudissements]
j'avais déjà quelques mots en tête et
d'autres 5 sacré après la gifle à bar à
lait sans le ton troisième au voile à
l'estragon score alors la biffe qu'est
ce que c'est bon ces gifles et une fille
avec trent c'est pas très conviviale
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on rassure pas sur france 2
dans le cisr info un chroniqueur va
avoir une petite galère avec son écran
tactile
le gars fait comme si de rien n'était
mais en bon informaticien il va faire la
manip très technique qu'on appelle dans
le jargon
je touche un peu à tous les boutons ici
on de gagner ton qui nous dit vous
n'avez pas parlé des nouveaux incidents
à la centrale nucléaire de
oui je vais essayer de vous montrer cela
même si vous voyez un ca vient de se
déconnecter alors que le flèche alors
c'est de pire en pire et arias qui
marchent à les contrôler à l'issue est
maire de mega faire bugger l'ordi jeu
mais c'est pas grave parce que vous nous
racontez ça très bien david frank de
sélestat donc là on est en alsace digne
brossé de
[Applaudissements]
alors gris fouillé si vous aussi vous
avez un talent venez nous rejoindre dans
le talent du jour ah ouais c'est tout de
suite vous allez voir qu'ils connaissent
à peine voilà christian christian
complètement bilingue il parle aux oies
comme ça couramment et christian le
talent de jours
il a beaucoup de talent il les fait
naître à la maison leur apprend à le
suivre n'importe où et connaît même leur
langage
vous avez vu ça il est pas de
télécommande vous en avez plus d'une
centaine à la maison vous allez adorer
ce qui suit c'est l'heure du à
chesapeake on adore le zapping on adore
tous les soirs 19h56 et au petit avec te
ment c'est maintenant et ça fait son vin
café au café atteindra vol d'une mariée
fait sa déclaration à son homme devant
sa famille en toute pudeur et en tout
place quand j'ai rencontré mon mari
c'était directement
[ __ ] est en fait la victime est
précise mais valeur tient au palais
l'économie juste avant tmp kelly v
novelli en profite pour sortir son chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'info du vrai le mag l'animateur
confond le chanteur pierre perret avec
un autre chanteur
l'économie est tout nu et tout bronzé et
c'est vrai que la ressemblance est quand
même assez profondes dans les 12 coups
de midi grosse ambiance avec el maestro
jean luc reichmann
[Musique]
alors
alimentation a pris les mesures du père
fouras pour son nouveau costume dans
fort boyard
[Musique]
suri départ de l émission de voyance on
voit on voit qui a personne qui appelle
un on va prendre un premier rappel tout
c'est annabelle des prêtres et semaine à
le bonjour à l'eau non ou pas allô allô
[Applaudissements]
allait bien je savais qu'on va enchaîner
cette année dans les onze voilà y'a une
candidat qui s'appelle yumi et yumi son
projet professionnel c'est devenir une
chanteuse de remplir des stades et de
faire tout plein d'albums mais quand il
rencontre un producteur à bas c'est
qu'on l'a oublié un truc c'est rare
chanter moi c'était dans la lah tonnes
autorisées
c'est sympa
c'est compliqué quand même sur le champ
c'est compliqué quand même pas disons
que pour une chanteuse effectivement
c'est ballot et là deux autres auraient
bien aimé le rencontrer ce producteur
c'était hier dans 4 mariages pour une
lune de miel et on était à sa d'une
victoire de la musique
[Musique]
oh
lens et loi no
[Musique]
sa chance est compliqué quand même
[Applaudissements]